salut maroni et comment il le bourgeois
alexandre mallet pas reparler dans les
quatre coins de l'île pour rencontrer
les guînes unis pour voir avec eux
comment les aides du département les
soutiennent et où mes parent est content
et paraît maroni pressé d'aller
rencontrer des réunionnais qui
bénéficient des aides du département et
jean n'a pas ce que ses idées sont
nombreuses effectivement il n'est bon
peu et moi aujourd'hui mais ça va dans
une maison d'accueil en famille au
connais pas ta ou à si je connais ce
sont des maisons qui accueille nos
gramounes et personnes en situation de
handicap pour les sortir de l'isolément
et soulager les familles donc on est
vraiment bien sûr que je connaisse pas
parce que je m'intéresse au dispositif
pour les jeunes que je connais pas ah
oui effectivement matière malok dossier
l on retrouve suite ok merci maroni a
bientôt faut aussi vous voyez savoir en
quoi consistent les maisons d'accueil
familiaux alors alors avec moi
[Musique]
oh
et
nous sommes à la maison d'accueil en
famille au le mini d'accueil à
saint-andré géré par l'association
racines au caire elle accueille des
personnes âgées ou en situation de
handicap ici il y a quatre maisons
individuelles et dans chacune d'entre
elles deux un client familiaux se
relaient pour aider offrir un cadre de
vie sécurisé et chats nouveau
bonjour madame raymond ça va bien très
bien madame raymond explication un peu
comme on trouve cette maison confortable
et calmont n'est pas ennuyés par
personne quand je vois la grande et
amauri les routes au moins quatre
personnes de ces
batailles occupe bien douce et oui oui
c'est notre demande d aller
[Rires]
chez moi me fait pas rester chez moi
comme le syndicat des cols à 12 mois à
24 mois tu es content merci beaucoup en
tout cas
les maisons d'accueil on a familiaux
sont gérés par toute une équipe pour le
bien des résidents et si honni d'accueil
celle qui assure la coordination c'est
natacha lac à natacha bonjourbonjour
attache à quel est l'intérêt d'une telle
maison la maison d'accueil l'uni
d'accueil se veut être une alternative
entre le domicile et l'ehpad qui est une
maison médicalisée aujourd'hui nous
avons beaucoup de gramounes à la réunion
qui sont isolés qui sont seuls chez eux
et qui ne nécessite pas réellement une
entrée en maison médicalisée donc le nid
d'accueil donc la maaf le nid d'accueil
le rapport justement ce cocon familial
cette convivialité et ce bien-être au
sein de la maison qu'est ce que vous
mettez en place au quotidien pour le
bien-être des résidents justement au
sein de notre maison on a des
professionnels qui interviennent donc
ils ont leur équipe médicale donc les
infirmiers qui interviennent ensuite on
a accueillant donc qu'ils sont sous
forme de roulement qui sont là 24 heures
sur 24 donc nous accueillent ne sont
jamais seuls merci natacha entrées pour
en savoir un peu plus sur le dispositif
je vais rencontrer et le dit et chef de
la direction de l'autonomie au
département de la réunion qui j'ai à ce
dispositif c'est elle qui fait le lien
entre le département et les organismes
qui s'occupent des maisons d'accueil et
le dit pouvez vous nous expliquer ce qui
a motivé le département à mettre en
place ce dispositif
alors la volonté du département est
d'apporter un cadre sécurisé aux
personnes âgées est en situation de
handicap qui peuvent être isolés en leur
apportant des modes d'habitat qui
s'adapte au mieux à leurs habitudes de
vie on la maaf a également vocation à
créer des emplois une masse emploie
environ 4 accueillants familiaux
équivalents temps plein c'est ainsi un
vecteur d'insertion sociale merci
beaucoup elodie merci
[Musique]
pour retrouver toutes les informations
prochainement les maisons
d'accueillantes familiaux rendez vous
sur le site du département
www.defirh.fr 4 point fr la dre
s'affiche en bas de votre écran voilà le
département des générations c'est fini
vous pouvez revoir cet épisode en replay
sur nos sites et réseaux sociaux je vous
donne rendez vous très vite pour un
nouvel épisode à bientôt
[Musique]
alors
alors là je vais à la rencontre d'un
agriculteur qui a bénéficié de l'aide du
département pour améliorer sa production
désolé je peux pas t'en dire plus là je
dois y aller je suis en retard
[Musique]